(audience cheering and clapping)
Our next guest is an Oscar winning actress, author,
businesswoman, mom, storyteller and overall game changer,
and I'm lucky enough to call her my friend.
We've actually known each other since we were about 14.
She is also the voice of Rosita the pig in the Sing movie,
the sequel Sing 2, which hits theaters today.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Please welcome the magnanimous, intelligent, beautiful,
bright, funny, wise, cool, Reese Witherspoon.
(audience cheering and clapping)
(upbeat music)
I tried.
Okay. Hi.
Oh my god.
(indistinct)
Get it, get it, get it, get it.
Looking good, by the way.
Well, I was excited to see you.
And this set is so gorgeous.
Well, you know, we are women who are fun-loving,
but we don't mess around when it comes to certain things.
But today we are celebrating nurses
and every member in this audience is a nurse.
(Reese and audience cheering and clapping)
Yay.
As a pioneer of the storytelling world,
the karma that you were raised by a mother who is a nurse.
Yeah, that's right.
Tell me about your mom.
Oh my gosh. You're gonna make me cry.
I was talking to my mom on the phone
when your producer called
and said the whole audience was filled with nurses
and my mom and I both started to cry
because being raised by a nurse,
I think my mother has such infinite compassion.
And there's my mom's first little ID card,
I think it was Memphis, Tennessee.
And she got to be in the newspaper
because she was one of the youngest nurses in Memphis.
But I remember being a teenager,
and my mother worked night shifts, she worked weekends,
so I had to kind of take care of myself,
my brother and I would make dinner and everything.
She was so tired, but she just loved her patients.
And she did labor and delivery, she did intensive care,
neonatal intensive care, and I would bring her donuts,
her and the other nurses,
but I was just in awe of her endless compassion
for other people.
And that's how I feel whenever I see a nurse,
because I think to dedicate your life to caring for people
is one of the most noble professions that exists.
So thank you for your incredible hard work,
taking people during this very difficult time.
(audience cheering and clapping)
And the fact that nurses are now the superheroes
and in the spotlight that every entertainer gets to be in
that they are the superstars and the cape wearers.
It should have never not been this way, but a silver lining
that can come out of this difficult time, this pandemic
that I wish we could have never had to experience,
but since we did, and we cannot change history,
as we live in the present and go into the future,
how can we make the world a different place?
We can put nurses on the pedestal
that they deserve to be on.
That's right.
(audience cheering and clapping)
I heard your mom had a good bedside manner, is that true?
Yes, my mom is awesome.
You know what's so funny?
She went to go get her COVID vaccine
and the lady who was gonna give her a COVID vaccine,
she said, can I tell you something?
'Cause my mom also taught nursing
at the state university in Tennessee.
That's right.
She goes, you were my professor.
Her name was Nancy. And she had been my mom's student.
I always reckon with just what you were talking about,
as an actor, we get so much attention,
but my mother and father,
my dad was a doctor, my mom was a nurse,
I've watched my mother save people's lives,
whether it was save a kid from drowning,
her very best friend had a bad accident
when we were very little
and I watched her resuscitate her on the side of a highway.
There is so much we don't focus and highlight on the people
who do that hard, difficult work of saving lives.
So I'm so glad that you're doing this today to highlight
and also encourage more people to be nurses.
It's such an incredible profession.
And it's always hard to get people to do it, you know?
And you think, it's so rewarding.
And I remember, even though my mom was tired,
she was like, I have purpose.
And having purpose in your life is such a big part
of being a human being.
What are we here for?
We're here to care for each other.
And you have a sense of purpose,
which I know you must embody
because you're pulling so many levers
and with keeping ego out of it,
I know you're aware of all the things,
you're just too smart not to be,
you're a 360 thinker and it's gonna be Christmas.
We're three days away from Christmas.
Yes.
I would love to know what Ava, Deacon and Tennessee,
what do you guys have planned, any traditions?
You know, we're just doing the regular stuff.
We're gonna be with my mom
and hanging out with the whole family.
Oh yeah, we dress up.
Trying to get all the family members in one picture
is really my goal for the year.
Why is it so hard to get the perfect screensaver?
If you have children, it is like,
it takes five years to get it.
I mean, really!
Someone has a weird face, someone's not,
the cropping doesn't work.
All I want for Christmas, is all my kids in one photo,
smiling, hopefully smiling.
I feel like I wanna call all of them and be like,
okay, this is what your mom really wants for Christmas,
but now Ava and Deacon are, what?
They are modeling for Beyoncé!
That's right. They did.
Holy cow, tell us everything.
(audience cheering and clapping)
They got called to be in Beyoncé's new Ivy Park Campaign
and they got to go and work together.
They had the best time.
(audience clapping)
Beyoncé was so sweet to them, so nice.
They got to be on set with her and her kids.
And of course, she's just the loveliest,
most creative human too.
She's a powerhouse.
Everything she does she touches with her artistry,
her creativity and her activism.
And they were just blown away.
The thing is they nearly passed out, they were so excited.
(upbeat music)